voilà déjà deux ans que Céline Dion est
absente sur scène comme dans les médias
mes médecins me suivent et je reçois des
traitements mais j'ai toujours d'espace
musculaires des problèmes de santé
avaient obligé la chanteuse à repousser
sa tournée européenne courage et il
avait privé de retrouver avec son public
je suis tellement désolé attristé
obligé de repousser les spectacles une
fois de plus
histoire et paru aux éditions Robert
Alfons c'est un livre très documenté
dans quelques mois on apprend plein de
choses une enquête choc de près de 300
pages menée par les journalistes
Laurence Piot et Hervé torpa qui dévoile
les secrets les plus intimes de la star
Céline Dion elle est si proche de sa
famille et son pilier on sait qu'elle a
très peu d'amis et ben voilà elle vit
comme une
ermite la maladie son entourage cet
ouvrage n'est pas un portrait de Céline
Dion que personne ne connaissait
auparavant c'est quelqu'un qui souffre
beaucoup physiquement et ce qui m'a
surpris évidemment sur les dernières
années c'est sa solitude immense si elle
annoncé trop bien tout le retour
notamment dans une comédie romantique où
elle jouera son propre rôle ce livre
risque de faire beaucoup de bruit alors
le livre choc sur la vraie histoire de
Céline Dion j'y crois ou j'y crois pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça marche toujours j'adore c'est une
machine pour être tout seul et vous
connaissez Céline personnellement oui
ou non
ensemble
pas de dîner et on se voit oh là là
madame madame
le livre vous l'avez lu ou pas
alors j'ai lu le mien mais non celui
l'autre
on sent bien que vous voulez mais on
sent bien que c'est un bouquin vous
aimez beaucoup on va commencer par le
dur un petit peu je suis désolé mais
cette histoire on va expliquer aux
téléspectateurs René accusé de viol dans
les années 2000 il faut comprendre que
le 18 mars 2000 René veut alors
installer Céline au César Palace à Las
Vegas il rencontre dans une salle de
jeux parce qu'il jouait beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent au jeu une femme
coréenne de 44 ans qui est une femme de
joie
par contre
qui portera plein de deux ans plus tard
pour viol elle accuse René de l'avoir
suivi dans sa chambre d'hôtel l'avoir
violé l'avoir menacé de mort si sa femme
Céline la prenait René il va il va lui
verser 2 millions de dollars contre son
silence mais ce qui dit lui c'est que il
a pas versé les 2 millions de dollars
parce qu'il l'a violé qu'il a accompagné
mais qu'à ce moment-là céline est en
train d'exploser de sortir son album et
qu'il ne voulait pas de scandale donc ça
ça sort de la presse maintenant c'est
c'est quoi cette histoire ce qui est
vrai qu'est ce qu'il est faut là-dedans
pourquoi ça sortirait maintenant
pourquoi ça ne serait pas sorti à
l'époque d'autre part c'est vrai que
c'est sortir à l'époque madame
confidentiellement parce que
c'est vrai que quoi que René quoi c'est
vrai que René était un joueur un vétérin
qui est passé des nuits à la table de
poker et qui effectivement est Céline le
savait avait tendance à aller voir des
dames de joie comme vous avez dit oui
oui oui et pourquoi et pourquoi parce
non parce que Céline d'abord a été folle
amoureuse de René et on est ne n'était
pas du tout ou fait l'amour d'elle donc
c'était pas à moi et il avait aussi une
vie disons sexuelle pour pas dire
c'est incroyable vous me dites que
Céline Dion j'ignorais et je ne juge
personne chacun se coupe Céline Dion
savait très bien que le soir quand il
jouait de temps en temps René aller
aller faire l'amour avec des
professionnels oui mais j'ai dit au
début de leur carrière au début quand
elle avait 12 ans
on fatigue et c'est vrai que elle a dit
souvent un jour il y a une femme
absolument éblouissante qui va me lever
elle l'a dit elle les met au point qu'il
accepte qu'il aille se coucher avec des
prostituées
et il le faisait est-ce que elle de son
côté de temps en temps s'est permis
quelques petites choses j'espère non
toute façon elle était pas une folle de
lui c'était pas une non elle était pas
un peu lesbienne
ça va être un raccourci d'employés ce
mot qui est tout de suite fait venir
tout le monde mais il est vrai que elle
a toujours eu et d'ailleurs elle est
près de LGBT très près toujours
en soutien elle ne veut pas qu'on les
emmerde quoi et donc c'est vrai que elle
a ce côté androgyne hein elle a quand
même pas des nénés comme ça elle est
plutôt bon assez plates elle est un peu
masculine elle a aussi un grand charisme
de femmes mais c'est vrai que ce n'est
pas
ni marine Monroe ni même un petit coup
de cœur voilà c'est ce que je voulais
dire pour une pour une femme
de coeur pour pépé Muno ce qui était
quand même un garçon qui aimait les
garçons oui uniquement mais pour une
fille non et pour une fille on ne nous
le dira pas c'est ça d'accord on a
compris Julie Snyder comme amitié
amoureuse l'animatrice non on a compris
la journaliste vedette qui a bien
construit la présence de Céline à la
télévision c'est vrai il y a pas de de
ces choses oui et moi j'ai entendu dire
que c'est l'inse elle avait fait 16 ans
de César Palace c'était pour payer les
dettes de René qui jouait tous les jours
au casino juste du bon billet tout elle
payait tout de toute façon
elle payait les déplacements le jet
privé elle payait tout évidemment pareil
qu'il pouvait perdre jusqu'à 3 millions
de dollars par semaine c'est arrivé et
puis gagner aussi la même somme une
autre fois il a une partie de diamant
qui est quand même le le champion du
monde de poker et il l'a offert tout de
suite d'ailleurs à Céline mais voilà il
perdait gagner et d'ailleurs Céline là
un jour seulement engueulé en lui disant
ça suffit de continuer à passer toute
nuit sur les tapis verts maintenant tu
vas rentrer et tu vas t'occuper le matin
de tes enfants parce que si tu joues
toute la nuit au poker le matin il y a
personne surtout si en plus après le
poker
[Rires]
mais non mais en tout cas on dit des
choses mais vous savez moi je trouve
très bien qu'on dise des choses presque
humaine sur Céline parce que ça me la
rend humaine on dit aucun couple un
couple c'est un contrat entre deux
personnes c'est 100 ans
et René à tout amené à Céline a tout
amené à René est-ce que vous me
dites-moi pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
choquant c'était un couple et ça ça
enlève rien à Céline qui ça reprend
presque humaine parce qu'en pensant
qu'elle était faite en cire tellement
les pattes de défaut alors il paraît
qu'elle était malade effectivement
pendant un petit moment et qu'elle a vu
le docteur Abitbol qui est un docteur
qui est très très réputé en France à
l'ORL et qu'on a enfin découvert la
véritable raison de sa maladie qui fait
qu'elle a été bloquée pendant un an
est-ce que c'est vrai ça on a découvert
sa maladie il faut quand même avoir la
conscience que Céline a été en surrégime
pendant peut-être 20 ans de sa vie vous
savez ce que c'est qu'une voiture qui
est en ce régime on dit moi j'y connais
rien mais qu'elle coule une bielle
attention c'est quand tu as pas mis
d'huile ça attention Isabelle
c'est une mauvaise vidange ça Isabelle
Elizabeth c'est pas du tout tu vois
quand le moteur il capoute
je vais vous dire Céline a été en sur
régime pendant 20 ans et elle a perdu le
soutien de sa vie le pilier de sa vie
René et le deuxième pilier de sa vie sa
mère donc après ces deux trucs là enfin
c'est de deuil là mon Dieu on voudrait
que elle émerge avec tout son talent non
pour la première fois il le dit elle
souffre un Agglobus c'est un sentiment
de boule dans la gorge des sortes de
spasmes qui se produisent en général
quand on avait qu'une période de stress
très agressive et le fameux médecin dit
elle va revenir sur scène mais je
préviens avec une voix qui sera
peut-être plus dans l'émotion mais qui
ne sera plus jamais aussi forte oui mais
aussi du renseignement au sans doute
dans l'émotion elle avait même dit que
désormais elle ferait des concerts
acoustiques
elle avait déjà prévenu
est terrible parce qu'elle ne se guérit
pas parce que c'est une maladie
imaginaire c'est qu'elle a l'impression
d'avoir quelque chose qui est de
déglutir et de chanter alors que tous
les gamins prouvent qu'elle n'a rien
d'intéressant le problème alors qu'elle
n'a rien on peut pas le traiter aussi
que les cordes vocales c'est un muscle
et que quand on vieillit bah ça s'abîme
comme tous les risques 53 ans bientôt 54
et c'est loin de moi de parler de l'âge
des femmes surtout pas mais c'est un set
moi je peux plus faire tu vois
je la montre moi ma note je la montre
moi
j'ai jamais pu on gagne du temps mais en
revanche je voulais vous demander
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des propos
dans Matthieu nous avait informé sur le
le comportement de la famille
de ces lignes par rapport à sa cousine
qui dit qu'elle est tordu qu'elle a les
jambes tordue
elle ne se parle plus avec sa sœur avec
le deck qui a décidé de faire une
carrière de chanteuse Claudette je
l'adore mais elle a quand même 65
quelque chose et bon ce serait parti
alors Claudette je l'aime beaucoup mais
disons que Céline a beaucoup donné à
tous ses frères et soeurs en maison
voiture cadeau bijoux elle a beaucoup
donné beaucoup elle pouvait elle pouvait
et maintenant que elle est un petit peu
dans sa forteresse un peu reculé du
monde retirer du monde pour quelques
temps il se dissout tiens mais si on
prenait sa place si nous si on était des
chanteurs
stars
c'est comme moi c'est un espoir depuis
20 ans
elle aura pas un petit peu de sa maman
quand même effectivement parce que sa
maman est paraît-il que c'était un vrai
personnage celle qui tenait toute la
famille d'ailleurs il paraît depuis
qu'elle est morte plus personne se voit
il s'appelle plus Céline Dion on dit
qu'elle prend plus personne au téléphone
c'était le lien c'est ça de cette
famille
entre tous et c'est vrai que souvent
c'est l'île je trouvais ça adorable elle
faisait monter tous ses frères et sœurs
sur la scène pour chanter deux trois
petits rigolons mais c'était charmant
parce qu'elle était pas obligé tous les
grands chanteurs de la terre ne font pas
monter leur famille sur scène et Madame
Thérèse Dion la tigresse
de de l'équilibre de Céline elle perdait
son équipe ça veut dire ça va être un
bordel que Céline va mourir avec les
noces là ça je peux vous dire c'est
quelque chose et alors effectivement il
paraît que ça se passait très très mal à
l'époque moi il y a un truc que
j'aimerais que vous me disiez parce que
vous me disiez vous me dites tout et je
pense qu'on nous ment sur quelque chose
lorsque lorsque René rencontre Céline la
première fois d'accord et qu'elle chante
dans son bureau avec qu'elle lui fait
trois semaines elle a 12 ans à peu près
14 elle a 14 ans et René s'occupe d'elle
et on nous fait croire dans tous les
documentaires et j'en ai fait que la
première fois que couche ensemble c'est
à l'Eurovision et qu'elle en a 19 c'est
ça à peu près ou 22 ou 19 d'accord bon
non est-ce qu'entre est-ce qu'entre 14
et 19 ans on nous prend pas pour des
imbéciles et on nous dit pas qui s'est
passé quelque chose mais il faut pas le
dire parce que c'est pas légal entre
flirté être un peu
couché ensemble il y a quand même un
petit précipice parce que Monsieur René
Angélil avait d'abord des enfants il ne
voulait pas choquer ses enfants était en
instance de divorce et ne voulait pas se
rendre coupable et en plus ça fait
vraiment ce je ne vous crois pas pendant
6 ans pour l'autre pendant 6 ans ils
étaient ensemble et je jugerai personne
quand elle avait 16 ans ils ont pas ils
ont pas plus de bisous tout à l'heure
c'est Céline qui était amoureuse de lui
au départ en tout cas sur les faits le
jour de l'Eurovision parce qu'il finit
par tomber amoureux d'elle parce que
c'est une adulte et peut-être qu'il l'a
différemment mais jusque là et vous
savez que Céline disait moi je n'ai pas
l'ambition d'être une grande chanteuse
ça ne le laissait sa mère qui avait
ambitionné pour elle moi je l'ambition
de séduire au nez angélique d'accord
elle a tout fait pour le séduire lui et
je continue avec vous parce que c'est
passionnant et je sais que des
spectateurs adorent parce que on apprend
vraiment vraiment des choses sa maman la
fameuse maman il paraît lorsqu'elle a
appris que René s'occupait de sa fille
mais pas que pour la musique
elle a littéralement dit je vais le tuer
un plomb et elle lui a dit en direct je
vais te tuer je ne m'abonne je ne veux
plus jamais ça vous pouvez le faire moi
je sais pas
je ne veux plus jamais te voir
évidemment la revue trois jours après
mais elle a voulu le oui quelque part en
elle il y a quelque chose qui a voulu
tuer René que René était un ami de la
famille ou quelque part à la confié sa
fille à un ami de la famille pour faire
une carrière et elle se rend compte
qu'au-delà de la carrière bon
finalement c'est un chaud lapin
puisqu'on a appris qu'après il y a un
compagnie oui mais de toute façon vous
êtes allusion à quelque chose
d'important c'est que elle était
absolument ancerclé de garde du corps
qui était ses frères et sœurs plus sa
mère évidemment la garde du corps en
chef qui était là pour éventuellement
flinguer le le violeur alors là j'ai un
truc annoncé d'incroyable c'est que
Céline effectivement je vais retrouver
ma fiche oh là là qu'est-ce que je suis
bordélique
[Rires]
[Musique]
donc cet été cette annoncé vendredi
matin donc il y a matin sur RTL Céline
Dion Céline Dion sera donc de retour et
se retourner en Europe de février à
septembre 2023 30 dates sont prévues et
l'improvisera donc pour s'installer
Royal Monceau l'hôtel pour six mois à
Paris et elle va enregistrer un nouvel
album en français est-ce que tout ça est
vrai s'il vous plaît une boule de
cristal pour l'instant on peut juste
croiser les doigts parce que une fois ou
l'annoncé deux fois on s'est trois fois
et je souhaite pour elle que ce soit
réalisable aussi ça fait trois ans que
j'ai des places
maison il faut le dire aux gens c'est
une maison qui a été construite dans un
endroit où il y a que des riches que des
maisons de riches ils sont que entre
riches et ne sort pas de chez elle et en
plus elle est dans une forteresse
dedans ses serviteurs dedans c'est
couturiers dedans elle est dedans
elle se rend pas compte qu'elle avait
besoin de l'amour de son public elle en
avait besoin et que elle arrive pas à se
remettre vraiment parce que justement
elle en est privé mais enfin en même
temps elle avait rêvé d'être une mère au
foyer qui est plus chez les pommes de
terre et qui mettaient les couches aux
enfants moi je le fais ça je peux dire
vaut mieux la maison milliardaire je
peux dire que c'est beaucoup mieux j'ai
une dernière question rapide les enfants
que vous étiez venu ici ça peut vous
arriver de vous tromper c'est très très
rare vous m'aviez dit elle est en train
elle aimerait bien adopter un enfant
c'est à 4 ans
oui il est où non elle est tombée
elle a trois garçons merci mon dieu mais
elle a pas de fille et elle a
effectivement suggérer à plusieurs
reprises qu'elle aimerait adopter une
petite fille et même une petite fille
asiatique mais non ça c'est pas fait en
tout cas mais vous avez été exceptionnel
Céline Dion et ce qui est de danse tout
ça c'est vrai Céline Dion icône et femme
de cœur par Elisabeth Frémont
et vous l'avez vu elle parle 4 elle dit
tout les amours les machins et si vous
avez la chance de côtoyer Céline et même
quand vous êtes sur des plateaux que
vous parlez elle continue derrière de
vous côtoyer tout donc je vous fais une
confiance aveugle oui elle me fait
confiance et elle a bien raison et on
s'est pris dans les bras et on s'est
compris et on s'aime et ben je vais
faire la même chose et on se retrouve
dans un instant à tout de suite